these people who purport to be all about
the minorities they pander to them and
la tinx they think that they're tacos
all of that stuff
and then their policies actually are
worse for them and then the guy that
they called racist you know for five
years basically his stuff kind of worked
uh but
hispanics or le tinx or tacos as uh jill
biden calls them uh breakfast tacos uh
they're not buying it anymore got a
quote here from fox news president
biden's approval rating among hispanic
americans has plummeted to 26 according
to a wednesday poll from quinnipiac
university and we should not be
surprised by this we should not they
have pandered beyond a belief
they have allowed illegal immigrants to
be conflated with legal immigrants which
upsets a lot of legal immigrants who are
here who are hispanic and this is
what they do so the racial slandering
and the woke politicking it's just not
working and on cnn
john king started asking people guys do
we have a problem with this joe biden
guy because this doesn't seem to be
working seeing this in your state in
georgia in the sense that you have
senator warnock who's trying to run for
re-election when he came into office and
helped flip the senate to the democrats
he was a big buddy of joe biden now you
go down on the battleground states like
georgia a lot of democrats are backing
off a little bit because they
politically think they need distance
there's quite a bit of distancing from
warnock's campaign from the president
sorry joe i don't know where you are or
what you're doing or probably who you
are at this point but they are done with
you man they are done with you and
whether you make it
to the midterms or not
i don't know whether they're going to
force you to step down or whatever or
they're going to use you as the
scapegoat after the red wave and they
just
just get rid of it right but it's
obvious they are done with joe biden
he's dead man walking and he doesn't
even know it he does not even know it
but it is just it is just and fair
because he
ushered in knowingly or unknowingly
ushered in all of this nonsense